i'm kristen desarebo the chief learning  officer at khan academy these are my  five learning science backed tips to  remember what you study the key is to  link it to something you already know  number one make a to learn list after  reviewing your materials put them away  and make a list of all the concepts you  want to learn number two explain each  concept to yourself review what you  understand in as much detail as possible  number three  check what you missed return to the  lesson and see if there's anything you  got wrong or forgot number four relate  to other concepts for each new concept  ask how is this similar to something i  already know how is it different number  five relate it to your own experience  ask does this relate to an experience  i've had how reviewing and relating  information to what you already know  helps store it in your long-term memory  read the blog post below for more  learning science tips